la moto cosa ucciso dai veri non ce la
fai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai la madonna che sto facendo
boom tutti morti tutti morti
vabbè primo vinto così a caso
figlio di tua madre che si deve infilare
nel deretano i vermi lo il culo in culo
nel senso che gli sono andato sul culo
questo crea anzi paolo vi al culo cosa
ho fatto lega cosa non è che questo mi
incula lo sapevo taccini sua madre tua
madre [ __ ] perché mi è tornato su
facebook perché mi ha aperto una foto di
johnny creek grandissimo no cosa come
cosa succeda il processo perché vi sia
aperta l'altra pagina
[Musica]
no vabbè è la madonna come l'api anarco
letto quanto grosso questo quanto
beh ragazzi fate finta no dimmi che
crepi in qualche vi supplico iddio
qualcuno lo faccia fuori vi prego
ragazzi se prova a resistere il più
possibile che probabilità o di vincere
se prova a resistere o oddio oddio cosa
succedendo
cosa sta succedendo nella settimana
scorsa fino adesso ho fatto un po di più
costoso fatto
[Musica]
contro stoffa 9 by pass ciao deficiente
marmato non ci credo
un deficiente brutto orgoglio lo stesso
gigante
so che mi avesse la ucciso era il
secondo è secondo l'ho ucciso l'ho
ucciso su non ci posso credere
quando vado
questa è va bè quanto sei scemo e tutti
i semi oggi o di all ansia
[Musica]
sai che succede morte morto moto come mi
sono salvato e quanta gente crepa tutti
i morti sono forte io sono forte
fortissimo che sarò ma non mi succede
quando sono primo no non è possibile
ragazzi però non ho capito ma se cosa
che si muovono danno più punti quanto ti
deve morire la famiglia da 1 a tua nonna
ma succede o è molto noi è molto noi non
sono sul linguaggio ok no oddio grande
madonna quanti punti ci sono in questo
punto ma vabbè quanta roba non mai visto
così tanti punti sluyter io da quando ci
gioco mai no ma dove mi sta un cinema
abbiamo anche lungo questo qua madonna
ma [ __ ] tua sorella
ho però si chiama come me banana banana
tutti
questo è un consiglio che vi dò io in
teoria non è possibile
madonna come ucciso come sono forte si
[Musica]
no luoghi ammazzo le famiglie un
maledetto la germania
[Musica]
ma da banco è morto anche lui quanta
gente ma se sbatti sull'anno f che
brutta frase ci sono riusciti veramente
[Musica]
in culo è bravo
oddio cosa ho fatto cosa ho fatto i culi
i culi che square frodo è morto è morto
il primo è morta primo è fatto pasqua
sono troppo forte io non ho fatto un
cazzo proprio i punti cazzo ciao zio
il mio è più lungo cioè il cuore che
batte a mille ogni volta che arrivano in
classifica non esco che a contenermi
prove vai al sodo ma perché ma si stanno
dando battaglia tutti oggi slither in
oman ha
ma lezione dai dai che crepa è morto
[Musica]
peccato voglia cosa è successo
cosa è successo a vela verso il gioco
succedono cose non ce l'ho fatta di moro
quanta gente morta in un solo punto ma
do sono miei titoli di ragazzo per
giocare all'inter io alla fine credo sia
l'insieme giusto l'insieme giusto
altro che va a sbattere perde armi pari
non ero pronto non vale sono il più
grande era un pò i [ __ ]
e c'è un motivo se mi chiamò berlusconi
che immette trovo così senza un cazzo di
motivo diventato grosso stanno venendo
tutti ma cosa ha fatto oggi va così così
bene che non so che cosa dire tu dire sì
se la v ma non avevo messo in curando
tutti quanti cioè non c'è oggi proprio
non c'e verso guardali e mamma mia che
partita ma dopo la piccola tissimo mai
bene veloce lo schiaccianoci veloce
veloce per cento di niente di niente di
male
[ __ ] tua madre ma in curatissimo
mi spiace amber sarai sicuramente
un'americana probabilmente anche [ __ ] ma
non posso farci niente se sei caduta
nella mia trappola
e così che rimorchio io tizia tiziano
ferro è il vincitore per il 9 più figo
di slither io da quando ci gioco è lui
tiziano ferro che è morto vabbè allora
quello che morde e vabbè sono morti
tutti sono primo adesso no non ci credo
non ci credo non ci credo non ci credo
non ci voglio credere porca put ho
cliccato il tasto branco in un'altra
pagina che si ce l'ho fatta e altro velo
[ __ ] e moris gino ma perché ma giuro
si è bravo prenditela con quel comune
nato a taglia ma che stavo per uccidere
pure lui dai sarebbe stata la causa del
secolo na litio sempre secondo moglie li
mortacci di tua sorella putrefatta
comicon brasiliano c'era il pitone
brasiliano ragazzi e grosso abbiamo
appurato in questo momento ecco per te
promuore bello di punti madonna vabbè
poi figlio di la noire è certo
[Musica]
e allora mi carica sono prendo tutti
tutti adesso pippo pippo non puoi
chiamarti pippo illegali in italia
chiamarsi pippo e vabbè non ci credo mai
mai nella vita
sì però se te ne deficiente che palle ma
perché lì si apre facebook e cazzo me ne
frega di gazzarrini corto cortissimo ma
vaffan
questo tenta di inglobare qualcun'altro
molin globo
[Musica]
ecco questo è più spaventoso di tutte le
morti che avete appena visto
sull'interista cosa ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo speciale su
questo primo speciale su twitter io ho
voluto farlo ragazzi perché erano un po
che non facevo un video speciale ma
comunque sia eravamo arrivati al decimo
episodio di sì l'iter io e ho pensato di
fare un episodio speciale appunto come
decimo episodio spero che vi sia
piaciuto lasciate un bel like qui sotto
è anche fatto lo mettere la vostra nonna
condividete di video sulla sua pagina
facebook come al solito spero che vedono
insieme ai 100 ragazzi cosa questo
argomento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e come mai violato tale
descrizione se non siete iscritti
iscrivetevi manca una pila ecco affetto
sono state discrete ci vediamo non fosse
un video da ragazzi
[Musica]